- Hello everybody, welcome.
I know people are still coming in.
I'm Stephen Pitti.
I'm professor of history,
American studies,
and ethnicity, race, and
migration here at Yale,
and I direct the Yale Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity, and Transnational Migration,
I wanna thank my colleagues in RITM,
Victoria, Mary, and Nicole,
for helping to put this together today.
Really excited to have all of you here.
I learned a long time ago
that one wants to listen
to everything that Laura Briggs says,
and read everything that
Laura Briggs writes about
many of the critical topics
facing the world right now,
ranging from transnational
feminist movements
to the politics of reproduction,
intersections of empire and
migration, the welfare state,
the health and safety of children,
the past and future of
neo-liberal governance,
and much, much more.
She's just one of the most
thoughtful, and most persuasive,
and most well-informed
people you'll ever meet.
Professor Briggs is
professor of women's gender,
and sexuality studies
at the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst.
She earned her PhD in American studies
from Brown University.
She's authored a number of field changing,
and prize-winning books including:
"Reproducing Empire:
Race, Sex, and U.S.
Imperialism in Puerto Rico."
"International Adoption:
Global Inequalities and the
Circulation of Children."
"How all Politics Became
Reproductive Politics:
From Welfare Reform to
Foreclosure to Trump."
And "Taking Children: A
History of American Terror."
And she's co-edited
important volumes including:
"Somebody's Children:
The Politics of Transnational
and Transracial Adoption."
And a special issue of "Meridians"
on "Radical Transnationalism:
Reimagining Solidarities,
Violence, Empires."
She's now working on a book entitled
"The Future is Born in Small Places:
The Gendered Biopolitics of
Freedom, Debt, Imperialism,
and a Natural Disaster in the Caribbean."
We'll have to have you
back when that book's done.
When Yale's RITM Center
considered who we'd like to invite
to deliver our fall 2022 lecture,
we knew right away that that
person was Laura Briggs.
An outstanding scholar
and a great teacher.
She's an active series editor
at the University of California Press,
a program builder who's worked
on the organizing collectives
of the Tepoztlán Institute
for Transnational History,
and the Thinking Transnational
Feminisms Summer Institute,
and in the Migration Scholars Collective.
And she's been an unceasing
and wise contributor
to public conversations through
her appearances on radio,
television and podcasts,
and in the print media.
Her talk today is entitled,
"Taking Children as a Tactic of Terror
Producing Neoliberalism,
and Making a Crisis of
Immigration and Asylum."
Thank you so much for
coming, Laura Briggs.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you Stephen for
that lovely introduction.
I have to tell you all, as
I was driving down here,
I was listening to an audio book.
I was listening to Celeste
Ng's "Our Missing Hearts,"
which is about lost children,
and it's about the fight
to even be able to tell the
stories of lost children,
so it was quite a
fitting thing to be doing
as I was trying to get
ready for this talk,
so thank you so much for
giving me this opportunity
to do just that.
So in April and May of 2018,
the Trump administration's policy
of separating children from parents
mostly from Central America
seeking asylum in the United
States made headlines.
Photos of children torn
from their parent's arms
filled the media in the United States,
and audio tape of separated
children in a shelter crying
seemed to be everywhere.
Calling the policy Zero Tolerance,
then U.S. Attorney General, Jeff Sessions,
and Homeland Security
Chief, Kirstjen Nielsen,
said "They were trying to deter people
from petitioning for asylum."
In the face of massive protests,
and a court order to reunite
parents and children,
the Trump administration
walked the policy back,
and announced they would no longer do it.
Nine months later, though,
children dying in customs and
border protection custody,
and a flu epidemic in a
detention camp in Texas
brought doctors and lawyers,
then lawmakers and activists to the camps.
Border patrol was, in fact,
still separating children from parents
more than 5,000 of them in total.
They were holding them for
weeks and months without beds,
blankets, showers, or change of clothes
in processing stations
designed to hold adults
for less than 48 hours.
One doctor described
the squalid conditions
where children were being held
as tantamount to the
intentional spread of disease,
calling them torture facilities.
Until the Trump administration figured out
how to use the pandemic
and public health laws
to exclude asylum seekers,
customs and border protection
deliberately targeted parents and children
separating them at the
border as part of a policy
meant to deter asylum seekers
from entering the country.
The cruelty was the point,
as Adam Serwer at "The
Atlantic" first said.
A widely circulated photo of a father,
and his toddler daughter
floating dead in the Rio Grande
suggested the terror
that asylum seekers faced
while being metered in
Mexico for weeks and months,
unable to cross the border
and petition for asylum,
and then forcing them into refugee camps
on the U.S. Mexico border like this one.
There's a great deal to criticize
in the Biden administration's
response to the asylum crisis,
especially from Latin America.
With a record low number of immigrants,
and refugees admitted to the U.S.
excepting the two years of the pandemic.
And what I want you to see on this slide
is that the ceiling for refugees
has been set quite high,
but the actual number of refugees admitted
is way down in that yellow orange line.
Until this month,
the Biden administration had
begun to empty refugee camps
of mostly Central American
migrants in Mexico,
like the one from the
previous slide in Matamoros,
camps that at their height
contain thousands of people.
This administration has actually worked
to reunite children and families,
successfully putting back
together around 500 of them
that were separated by
the Trump administration,
although, 200 still
remain lost to each other.
In recent weeks as a new
wave of Venezuelans flee,
economic collapse at home,
shelters and encampments in
Mexico have begun to fill again,
even more seemingly under
pressure from Washington,
rumor has had it that Mexican officials
are pushing Venezuelans
still further south
across the border into Guatemala.
And even as the Biden administration
is engaged in lawsuits
to end expulsions under Title 42,
the public health measure that's
been used to deport people
since the COVID pandemic began
without any semblance
of an asylum process,
it has recently expanded
such expulsions again
by using them against Venezuelans,
just as it did months ago to Ukrainians.
Above all, of course,
what people need from the
U.S. immigration system
is a simple, efficient,
and predictable pathway to citizenship,
not the Byzantine arbitrary,
and capricious system we have now.
Children and adults are crossing borders
for any number of reasons,
but these include importantly
seeking to reunite
after many decades of a
racialized labor system
in the United States that
wants immigrant workers,
but not their households,
not children, not elders.
The ongoing disruptions of everyday life
for impoverished people
in Central America,
Venezuela and Mexico
has produced an asylum crisis,
and this includes the ways
that the IMF, World Bank,
and NGOs have methodically
destroyed national governments
in many nations in Central America,
opening the door to corruption,
and to drug cartels taking
over municipal governments,
and incorporating themselves as NGOs,
building organizations
that extend from Honduras
to the U.S. Southwest
made much worse by state sponsored
violence in the aftermath
of the U.S. sponsored
coup in Honduras in 2009,
and contested elections in 2017.
The ways opponents of the child
separation policy organized
both helped and hindered the effort
to address these problems.
The first thing we have to acknowledge
is that there's nothing
exceptional about taking children
from their kin and caregivers.
This has been a practice
up and down the Americas
for four centuries,
targeting single mothers,
and others without
heteronormative families,
especially enslaved people
and members of tribal nations.
Treating child separation as remarkable,
in some ways kept us from
actually stopping it,
as it allowed the Trump
administration to claim in 2019
that it was just taking
children from parents
who had been neglectful,
or who had a criminal history.
We've not been good ever
at addressing the ways these charges
have a history in this country
of being directed at Black,
and Indigenous communities in rebellion,
and all the people Cathy
Cohen identified as queer,
the welfare mothers,
the single moms, the unruly youth,
and all those who are
bad at nuclear families.
In order to understand
the Trump era policy
of taking children from asylum seekers,
and putting them in detention camps,
we need to ask how Central Americans
were made into the sorts of people
who could be dispossessed
of their children.
How did it come to be
in the spring of 2018
that immigration officials
walked the bridge of the Americas
between Juárez in Mexico,
and picked Central Americans
out of crowds of people
from every country, continent,
and island that walked that sky bridge?
Why were Central Americans
in particular told
that the United States was
full and they could not cross?
As one immigration activist said,
"If you look Indigenous or
you look Central American,
they will stop you.
They never ask why you are coming.
They just say they can't receive you."
The policy didn't spring fully formed
from the head of a Trump
administration official in 2018.
It had a history in the
anti-communist civil wars
of the latter part of the 20th century
when Central Americans first
began losing their children
to state terror.
Latin Americans in the
1960s, '70s, and '80s
saw child taking by those
who sought to instantiate
neoliberalism across the region
through anti-communist rhetoric.
There in the space
between Henry Kissinger,
and Ronald Reagan's
America, fascist Spain,
and Latin America's own
autonomous nationalism,
militarism, and right-wing Catholicism,
increasingly paranoid
anti-communist states
sought to rigidly control
not only the present,
but the future.
Military dictatorships
up and down Latin America
from Guatemala to Argentina,
directed campaigns of
torture, assassination,
and disappearance.
While initially these right-wing
military dictatorships
targeted armed leftist guerrillas,
their victims grew more diverse
as they quickly overwhelmed,
and largely killed actual militants,
turning to those
who supported anything
even vaguely socialist
from unions to students
to agrarian cooperatives.
Then they took their children
hoping to ensure that the very young
who might have been touched
by their parents leftist ideas
were violently uprooted and reeducated
in conservative adoptive families,
or outside the country.
This right-wing dream of killing ideas
by burying their proponents,
and taking their children was a failure.
As the extent of torture,
and especially the kidnapping of children
became known to ever wider circles,
there were first efforts
to prosecute them.
In 2006, Jorge Rafael Videla,
once the most powerful man in Argentina
as its military dictator,
went to prison together with
a number of his collaborators,
not for his responsibility
for torture, murder,
and disappearances,
but rather for kidnapping children,
and running an illegal adoption ring,
while he was the defacto president
in the late '70s and early '80s.
While the Argentine Congress
had tried to grant a general
amnesty to the former leaders
to prevent their prosecution
for the crimes they committed,
as they oversaw hundreds
of torture centers,
and while giving orders for
the military to kill civilians,
a judge found that the official pardon
didn't cover child kidnapping
because it was an ongoing crime
continuing after the
final date of the amnesty.
Kidnapped infants and children
turned out to be the crime
they could be prosecuted for,
and it's what held them in prison
until the amnesty was
finally repealed in 2005.
In El Salvador in the late 1970s,
more and more people despaired
of free and fair elections
as demonstrating for
them got people killed,
and they turned to support the
leftist military guerrillas.
In the U.S. the Carter
administration to a small degree,
and then the Reagan
administration massively
gave a corrupt Salvadoran state support
in the form of training for the military.
They gave them weapons, military advisors,
and ultimately about one to
two million U.S. dollars a day
to prop up a brutal and
unpopular government.
The Salvadoran government
held power through terror,
detentions and disappearances,
death squads that left
bodies in the streets
as a warning to others about
opposing the government,
and massacres of civilian communities
that were suspected of
support for the guerrillas.
During the armed internal conflict,
an estimated 75,000 civilians were killed
in a country of only five million people.
The overwhelming majority died
at the hands of the military.
Military and paramilitary
forces in El Salvador
also took between 800 and 1,000 children.
During the conflict, the
military sought to eliminate
the social base of the guerrilla.
Drawing on the U.S. military's
paradigm in Vietnam,
they sought to eliminate
the water, the fish,
of the guerrillas swam in,
engaging in a scourged earth
campaign against civilians,
and creating model villages
surrounded by barbed wire,
and guarded by military
and paramilitary units
in place of autonomous communities.
Their goals included breaking
people's will to resist
by sowing terror including
of losing children,
and as in Argentina to control the future
by refusing to allow those
suspected of being communists
from raising a next generation.
Sometimes children became
lost in the confusion
when military threat
forced communities to flee.
Others were picked up right
in front of their parents,
and there were cases
where they were literally
ripped from their mother's arms.
According to their
reconstruction and research
from the stories of surviving relatives,
human rights groups
attributed 90% of the
child disappearance cases
to the military,
and 10% to the guerrillas.
In late May and early June of 1982,
to take only one example,
in the events that became
known as the Guinda de Mayo,
the Flight in May,
people ran from their homes
because they were tipped off
that paramilitary groups in the army
were planning to come to
their homes and kill them,
believing that they were
supporters of the guerrillas.
The military called
this Operation Clean-Up,
Operación Limpieza,
designed to wipe out communities
in Northeast Chalatenango.
People fled from one community to another
with soldiers on their heels
who killed anyone they found.
They slaughtered animals and
destroyed homes and crops.
These forces also took
at least 11 children,
including Ernestina and
Erlinda Serrano Cruz,
ages three and seven.
When the Serrano Cruz
family began running,
the mother and a brother made
it past military barricade,
and went in one direction,
while the father, brother and sisters,
Suyapa, Ernestina and
Erlinda went in another.
After three days of walking,
they made it to a settlement.
They hid there for another three
days without food or water,
but finally the brothers
went to search for water.
Ernestina and Erlinda, small
children alone began to cry,
tipping off soldiers
to the their presence.
Suyapa was not far away,
but she had a six-month-old baby,
and she had tried to protect her family
by hiding separately
in case the baby cried.
She later reported that
she heard one soldier ask
if they should take Ernestina
and Erlinda, or kill them.
Another replied that
they should take them.
When she no longer heard the soldiers,
Suyapa went and searched for her sisters,
but they were gone.
The little girls were never found.
After the war, a human rights group,
la Asociación Pro-Búsqueda de
Niñas y Niños Desaparecidos,
the Association For Searching
For Disappeared Children
began the painful work with families
of trying to find children
disappeared during the war.
They found about 500, some
of them adopted in Europe,
some in the United States,
others in Salvador,
and continued to look for others.
While it took decades of
work for their lawyers,
the case that ultimately
broke open the impunity
surrounding the military child taking
was that of the Serrano Cruz girls.
The Inter-American Court of
Human Rights ruled in 2005
that the state was responsible
for their disappearances,
and demanded that it opened
its records to help find them,
and form a national search
commission, which it did,
albeit not until six years later.
The court also found
that the military unit
that took the girls was the
infamous Atlacatl Battalion,
responsible for numerous massacres,
and atrocities during the war.
This is particularly significant
for the still unanswered question
of whether U.S. military,
and intelligence advisors
widely believed to have
trained Salvadorans in torture,
and responsible for their
scorched earth strategy,
were also involved with Salvador's
child kidnapping policy.
The Atlacatl Battalion was
trained by the U.S. military
in the School of the
Americas in North Carolina,
and was directly advised by them
once they returned to El Salvador.
"The New York Times" called the battalion
the pride of the United
States military team
in San Salvador.
Even if U.S. advisors did not
directly urge child taking,
and we don't know if they did or didn't,
it's difficult to believe
that they never heard anything about it.
Some children were even
living in military barracks,
and every child who was adopted
transnationally to the U.S.
passed through the U.S.
Embassy in San Salvador.
As Robert White, U.S.
ambassador to EL Salvador
in 1980 and '81 said of the efforts
to cover over the horrors of
what the Salvadoran leadership,
and military was doing by
the Reagan administration,
and to a lesser extent the Bush
and Carter administrations.
The Salvadoran military knew that we knew,
and they knew when we
covered up the truth.
It was a clear signal that at
a minimum we tolerated this.
If they knew and didn't speak against it,
U.S. officials aided and
abetted child taking.
Although Guatemala shares
a border with El Salvador,
they're quite different kinds of places,
and the civil wars had
very different dynamics.
One could say that about
the Central America region as a whole.
Nicaragua, the guerrillas won.
In El Salvador, they almost won.
In Guatemala, they had an uphill battle,
but were stopped by genocide
when they were beginning to make progress.
And in Honduras, in part due
to the U.S military presence,
they never got off the ground.
Guatemala is much larger than Salvador,
and its people speak more
than 20 different languages.
About half are Indigenous,
many of whom live in remote
communities in the Highlands
that are a day's walk from any road.
If El Salvador is finally
coming to a reckoning
with child taking in the 1980s,
Guatemala's encounter
with its Cold War horrors
is still ongoing and
perhaps a losing battle.
El Salvador has a
relatively complete counting
of the hundreds of children
that were lost during the war,
and many of them have been found.
Guatemala lacks anything
like a comprehensive account
of the more than 5,000
children who are disappeared.
There a paranoid Latino ruling
class feared the autonomous,
non-Spanish speaking
Indigenous Mayan communities.
Some like the Q'eqchi' speaking Maya
of a remote region of the highlands.
That's a picture of somebody
in an Q'eqchi' community,
were identified as a group as subversives,
guerrilla sympathizers are worse,
and targeted for elimination.
While the military rulers
denied it to the world,
and most Guatemalans in
the major urban areas
tried to pretend it wasn't happening,
the military committed atrocities,
and massacres in the highlands
slipping into communities
in the early morning hours,
and killing everyone,
destroying crops, killing
animals, burning homes.
They reveled in gruesome ways
to end the life in a human body,
whether of men, women, or children.
They raised 440 communities
with the intimate,
and extensive cooperation
of U.S. military advisors in the CIA.
Where they didn't assassinate,
they captured people and
disappeared children.
The effects of taking small
children and disappearing them
are similar everywhere.
The exquisite pain of
the loss of a loved one,
compounded by the uncertainty
of what happened to them,
and the agony of having failed someone
who was so deeply dependent on you.
Here's a quote from somebody in Guatemala.
My name is Feliciano Raymundo,
and I remember that after
they disappeared Jose in 1982,
they killed my husband and
disappeared my other sons.
I became ill from the
pure sorrow and suffering.
During the following 18 years,
I was able to find three of my sons,
but I wasn't able to learn about my Jose.
I don't know what happened.
Sometimes I thought
that maybe he had died,
and other times I felt that he was alive.
I always kept alive that
hope and I wondered,
who does my son live with?
Could he be married?
Where would he be living?
Other days, sadness would
get the better of me,
and I would think that
it would've been better
if I hadn't left him with someone
in a place where she thought
he would've been safer.
If I had done other things in those days,
surely Jose would not have been lost.
Survivors grieved without resolution.
The armed forces in the
paramilitaries in Guatemala
did not kill all the
children they picked up.
They also took them
to other Indigenous
communities for adoption,
or dropped them off at orphanages
where they made their way to Europe,
or the United States
and adoption sometimes,
or took them to towns and cities.
One of the tactics of the vast
bureaucracy of the military,
and intelligence services,
which effectively
encircled the entire nation
through its network of orejas,
of informants and spies,
was to pit Indigenous
peoples against each other.
The goal of disappearing children
was the logic of ideological
and genocidal elimination
to disrupt the transmission
of languages, ways of life,
the practical arts of
weaving huipils or blouses,
to eliminate ways of thinking and acting.
Sometimes even during the war,
people would learn that their
children were still alive,
but growing up in a community
that spoke a different language,
and was loyal to the government.
On the one hand they
spoke of it being a relief
to find them alive,
but they were also full of grief
to find that their children
were now in some sense
also part of the enemy
that might return to kill
them and all their community.
The Peace Accords were
officially signed in 1996,
but the civic process of building
peace was never completed.
The now grown children who were kidnapped
are still searching for their
families and communities
while parents and relatives
keep looking for them.
As elsewhere in Latin America,
family members of Los desaparecidos
were a political force
demanding that children who
are taken alive be found.
Unlike in El Salvador
or Argentina, however,
in Guatemala the same people
who were found responsible
for acts of genocide by
the Truth Commissions
often stayed in power.
Two reports from the archbishop's
Commission on Human Rights,
one in 1998, the other in 2000
collected testimony on first
216 children disappeared alive,
and later than 444.
This latter report, "Hasta Encontrarte"
"Until You Are Found"
focused exclusively on
disappeared children,
and suggested that there
were many, many more cases.
In 1999, a number of groups of
relatives of the disappeared
came together to begin the massive task
of trying to reunite
children with the families
who lost them under the
umbrella of (indistinct)
By 2008, they had organized 650 reunions
bringing together translators,
often more than one,
since many monolingual speakers
of Indigenous languages
were involved,
and gathered the resources
for the often long trips
across the country on buses and on foot.
These emotional reunions often brought out
whole communities to celebrate,
though, the renewed
connections were often fleeting
in the face of the expense of travel,
and the absence of a shared language.
While most of us know something,
and many of us know a lot
about Central America's wars,
and the U.S. sponsorship of them,
now I wanna talk about
the more clandestine war,
the part that was funded by drugs.
The Reagan administration
played a much bigger role
than policy experts
usually want to acknowledge
in birthing the contemporary
era of drug cartels,
and drug trafficking,
although, the general
outlines were laid out
in the Iran-Contra hearings,
and subsequently,
the Kerry Commission Hearings
on drugs and foreign policy.
Obviously, part of this
was just destroying the
formal economy through war.
So-called development loans,
and bringing to power a ruling
class that shrank the state,
and often did nothing to build healthcare,
education or food subsidies,
leaving the informal
economy, drugs in particular,
is one of the few ways to make a buck.
And literally in El
Salvador it's a buck, right?
They're using U.S. currency,
but also when Congress cut off funding
for the anti-communist
wars in Central America,
it became clear that
the kinds of militaries,
and paramilitaries
that the Reagan
administration was supporting
were engaged in torture, disappearances,
and bodies in the streets,
and kidnapping children.
A shadow U.S. government operation
allowed them to fund
themselves in shady ways,
including flying bricks of
cocaine into U.S. cities
on military planes.
Indeed, these networks are the origins
of the current cartels
that are terrorizing impoverished people,
especially women and children
throughout Central America,
and Mexico, and sometimes
the U.S. as well,
driving the current asylum
crisis on the southwest border.
The 1980s was also when
children seeking refuge
from Central America's wars who walked,
or got a ride across the U.S. border,
started being held in cages.
Despite the Trump exceptionalism
that led many to believe
that child separation for
asylum seekers was new,
Central American children have
been sent to detention camps,
and separated from their
parents for decades.
First Mexico and
secondarily Central America
came in the 20th century
to function as a kind of
labor reserve for the United States.
Agribusiness, service industries,
and the construction sector
alongside employers of
housekeepers and nannies
relied on being able
to access a labor force
that under the shadow of deportation
could be expected to work cheaply,
and outside the system
of labor protections,
like minimum wage.
In time of labor oversupply,
these same workers could be
pushed back into Latin America.
In times of shortage,
more could be recruited.
The arrival of large numbers of children
signaled the death of this
tacit bargain however.
The deal was essentially
that workers would not
stay in the United States,
although that was always a
fantasy more than a reality,
and employers in local communities
would not pay the costs
of reproducing the labor force.
Children would stay in home
countries to get educated,
get their healthcare,
and grow to an age where they
could be of use as workers.
When people became too
old or disabled to work,
they'd be forced back across the border.
In this way,
Latin America functioned like
South Africa's homelands,
or Bantustans under apartheid,
a reserve where women,
children, and elders
were expected to subsist
off a worker's remittances,
or whatever farming
they could scratch out.
In the 1980s,
the system began to
falter in Central America
as adults and children fled wars at home.
Women became a larger and
larger group of migrants,
often bringing children
across the border as well.
By the 1990s with the Bill Clinton era
militarization of the border,
the system broke down even further
as workers could no longer
return to home countries
to birth or father children,
renew relationships with
children or partners,
or visit elders as they were dying.
By 2014, when Central American children
started arriving unaccompanied
in significant numbers,
it was clear that the
border militarization,
and deteriorating conditions of violence
victimizing impoverished
people in the region
had completely destroyed the old system.
Unaccompanied children
actually began filing
asylum petitions in numbers after 2000,
claiming a human right to safety
as drug cartels, police
violence and impunity,
economic collapse and gangs
threaten their wellbeing
in order to continue to feed
the apparently insatiable
appetite for drugs
in the United States.
U.S. social policy continued
to try to keep the old
labor agreement in place.
Its collapse was why conservatives
and white nationalists
were and are in a dead panic
about small children crossing the border.
As soon as there were significant numbers
of Central Americans
in the U.S. Southwest,
there were children in detention camps,
and separated from their parents.
Most sought to find relatives,
and disappear into the general population,
which became easier
as Central American
immigrant communities grew.
While many slipped across
the border unnoticed,
the unlucky ones were
picked up by the INS,
between 7,400 and 8,500 children a year
between 1987 and 1993.
They were strip searched, detained,
and then usually released
to parents or guardians
to await hearings on immigration charges.
There were also for a time
large, sprawling Red Cross camps
at the Texas Mexico border
that housed Central American families.
In 1985, Jenny Lisette Flores
was part of a group of children
who were held for months,
or years as a result of new INS rules
that prevented her release to a guardian.
The INS, the Immigration
Naturalization Service,
I just looked around and realized
that some of you have
only known it as ICE,
decided it would only
release children in custody
to a mother, father, or
grandparent, aunt or uncle,
and only if they could prove
that they were in status
in the United States.
If Jenny Flores' mother had picked her up,
she would essentially
be turning herself in
as an undocumented immigrant,
and become subject to deportation.
Her husband had been
killed in El Salvador,
and this was not something
she was willing to do.
So instead she turned to Carlos Holguín,
an attorney with the National
Center for Immigrant Rights.
Holguín took the Reagan
administration to court
on immigrant child detention,
the conditions under
which children were held,
and the question of whether
they should be detained at all.
He sought to get Jenny
Flores released to a cousin
arguing that she was better off with him
than in an old hotel
that had been converted
into an immigration detention facility,
sharing a room with three
adult male strangers,
strip searched with no
minimal standards enforced
for health, sanitation,
or access to education, or
age appropriate diversions.
The court and the INS proved
much more willing to clean up
the conditions of immigrant
detention for children
than to release them.
The Flores case ultimately
split into three,
one on strip searches,
one on whether refugee
and immigrant children
could be detained at all.
And one subsequently on the
conditions of that detention
in Flores v. Meese.
In 1987, the Reagan
administration tentatively agreed
to safer and more humane
conditions in detention,
the Flores v. Meese settlement agreement.
The Flores agreement, which
is still in force, supposedly,
stipulated that children would
only be held for a few days
in the least restrictive setting,
a licensed non-secure facility
to determine whether
they should be deported,
or reunited with relatives.
Otherwise, they would be
placed in foster homes,
or licensed facilities with
age appropriate programs.
The most important part
of the Flores litigation,
in my view,
was the Supreme Court case
to determine whether children
should be put in immigration
detention at all.
The Reagan and first Bush administration
aggressively defended the
practice of holding about
2,000 children a year.
They sought to keep detaining children
even after the Ninth Circuit ruled
that they had released them to relatives,
appealing it to the Supreme
Court in Barr v. Flores.
And, yes, that Barr, Bill Barr,
also, the attorney general under Trump.
In that case,
the government's strategy
was to defend detention
by arguing it was humane and homelike.
Advocates for migrant children
painted a much different picture,
citing nine different
child advocacy groups
who testified to shackling, barbed wire,
arbitrary punishment, inadequate food,
lack of access to counsel or phones.
One youth who was subsequently
sent to juvenile hall
in California described
the vast improvement there
over INS detention conditions.
In 1993 by a five-four majority,
the high court ruled in
favor of keeping children
in detention,
with Antonin Scalia
writing for the majority
that where the conditions
of government custody
are decent and humane,
such custody surely does not
violate the Constitution.
In his dissent,
Justice Stevens insisted
that on the contrary,
jailing children for offenses
that were legally as weighty
as a parking ticket was obscene.
During the Clinton years little changed.
About 200 children were being held
in long term immigrant
detention at any given time,
some of whom, though not
all, had requested asylum.
In 1997, a Human Rights Watch report
damned the practice of jailing children,
particularly those who were
lawfully present in the U.S.
because they had petitioned for asylum,
and called on the INS to
release children to relatives,
or child welfare agencies
to inform them of their legal rights,
and to provide education and
books in detention center.
The report was embarrassing
to the Clinton administration,
and so it finally
concluded the negotiations
over the Flores settlement
begun under Reagan.
If children must be held,
it would be under safe
and sanitary conditions
in a licensed child welfare facility
with access to food and
water, medical care,
adequate temperature control and lawyers,
and segregated from unrelated adults,
and young prisoners charged with crimes.
Unfortunately, the Flores agreement
was never sufficient in itself
to deter abuse by immigration officials.
The George W. Bush administration
detained small children
with their parents,
and unaccompanied minors
under far harsher conditions
than the Clinton
administration, or even Reagan.
Following the September 11, 2001 events,
the Bush administration
began separating children from
parents for the first time,
and parents from each other.
Instead of family detention,
they, like the Trump administration,
subsequently created
a legal fiction of these
being unaccompanied children
by virtue of having been
separated from their caregivers
by the INS,
which is exactly what
the Trump administration
subsequently did.
An Amnesty International report in 2003
called attention to these conditions,
and they found the second
Bush administration,
and customs and border protection,
essentially ignored the Flores
rules for child detention.
According to Amnesty International,
child migrants were
spending years in detention
without judicial review of their claims.
To stay in the U.S. strip
searches had been reinstituted.
They were housed with
juveniles convicted of crimes,
beaten by guards,
and subjected to solitary
confinement for infractions
like poor sportsmanship, swearing,
or even grammatical mistakes.
Children as young as seven
were brought to immigration
hearings in shackles
with belly chains and leg irons.
In 2005, the Congressional
Appropriations Committee
ordered the Bush administration
to stop separating families,
telling them to use ankle monitors
to ensure parents appeared
at their asylum hearings.
Rather than release families, though,
the Bush administration
expanded family detention.
Where the previous system
had relied on a single small facility,
the Berks Detention
Center in Pennsylvania,
the Bush administration
opened a much larger one
to hold more families,
the T. Don Hutto Detention
Center near Austin, Texas.
It quickly became a symbol of
the abusiveness of the system.
A former medium security prison for men,
it lacked the green space of Berks,
a former nursing home that
housed up to 84 people,
and it was characterized
by cells and long hallways
with bars on the windows with
capacity for more than 500.
It was a dramatic change in
the treatment of families
seeking asylum
who were lawfully present
in the United States,
who had previously usually been
released into the community
to await their hearings.
At Hutto children of refugees
awaiting hearings on asylum
claims were denied schooling,
trapped all day in cells
either with unrelated adults,
or their parents with no
recreational facilities.
They weren't even allowed
crayons or pajamas.
The ACLU and others filed lawsuits
to stop the separation of children,
and other practices that
had said were prohibited
under Flores resulting in
a new settlement agreement,
again, promising to
minimize family detention,
and the separation of
children and parents.
Whoops.
Oh wait, I really do want that slide.
So in 2020, and particularly
with the COVID-19 crisis,
the Trump administration
began to actually accomplish
what it had long set out to win,
the effective unraveling
of the asylum system
put in place after World War II.
First, they learned what
the Obama administration
understood all along which was that legal,
and bureaucratic undermining
of the system works better
than making children cry
in front of reporters and activists.
Beginning in 2019, Trump
administration took children
from their parents seeking asylum
under the pretext that their
parents were criminals.
There's not much history in
the U.S. of defending parents
who've been criminalized no
matter how slight the crime,
and the mass demonstrations in the street,
and persistent editorials stopped.
Then they reactivated
the Obama-era program
of trying to stop asylum
seekers in Mexico,
Plan Frontera Sur.
Officially, ICE gave
some people their due,
their right to an asylum hearing,
but metered their crossing
into the United States,
then sent them back across
the border into Mexico
to live in UN funded refugee
shelters in tent cities
to await hearings that never came
in the midst of the dangerous landscapes
of the border region where
many were victimized again
by the same transnational
mafias and cartels
that they had fled in Central America.
With the COVID crisis,
even these limited forms of
access to refugee hearings
were reduced to the nearest trickle.
Border patrol agents were
ordered to deport essentially
any non-citizen found near the border,
including children under Title
42 of the Public Health Code,
claiming that their goal
was to avoid exposing
asylum seekers to COVID
in congregate settings.
ICE essentially suspended
the asylum system.
And we will continue to
need an asylum system,
or something like it
to address the aftermath
of wars in Central America.
Decades of intervention
by international financial institutions,
and non-governmental
organizations that shrunk,
and replaced the functions
of federal government
in Central America
have by design dramatically
weakened Central American states
in order to promote free markets.
Power abhors a vacuum and
the cartels rushed in.
Local officials, the police, gangs,
and international crime syndicates,
increasingly became the same entities,
often with the endorsement,
and support of the Trump administration
during his presidency.
Murder rates for impoverished people
at the hands of all
these groups skyrocketed
as they were increasingly
forced to pay for protection
to drive a taxi, or run a store.
People of humble means,
particularly women,
queer and trans folk, youth
and children fled in droves
seeking asylum in the
United States and Mexico.
I wanna conclude by way
of this image of a protest
at Fort Sill where the
Trump administration
sought to house 1,600 migrant children.
Fort Sill began as a POW
camp during the Indian Wars
where the Apache leader Geronimo died.
A century later,
it housed Japanese American
detainees during World War II.
This group pictured here,
a coalition of members of
the movement for Black Lives,
Japanese, Jewish, and Native activists,
stopped it from becoming
a detention facility
for migrant children.
As we watch as the Biden
administration tries to figure out
whether it will continue to
expel thousands of people,
and it is,
or honor its campaign promise
to listen to what the majority of people
in the United States actually want,
which is increased migration,
a just rapid asylum system,
and a pathway to citizenship
rather than a racialized labor system
that consigns some people to
exploitative jobs in fields,
and people's homes,
threatened always with the
risk of losing their children
in order to keep them in line.
We need to honor the history of protest
against child taking,
and remember that people
in every generation
have stood against it.
I'll stop there, thanks.
(audience applauding)
- [Stephen] Laura, are you
happy to take questions?
- I'm more than happy to take questions.
- [Audience] Hello, great.
Thank you so much,
professor, this is great.
I have a question, I guess about,
I would love to hear your
thoughts on the racialization,
like the history of the
racialization of families,
and also the racialization of the border,
and how this episode of zero
tolerance family separation
is where those two
histories sort of intersect,
and if there have been
moments in the past?
Your lecture, like, speaks to that,
but I would love to hear your thoughts
a little bit more on that, yeah.
- Thank you.
So the family has always been
a technology of racialization
in the United States.
It's remarkable given
all the counterevidence
in front of us every day
that we imagine families to be a site
where people are racially
homogenous, right?
And the other thing that
we do with the family
is to see all non-nuclear
families as potentially,
also, non-white.
And we know this through
the image of a figure like
the welfare queen and her kin
who also turns up as sort of
the anti-hero of the
culture poverty narrative,
the figure that centers overpopulation,
which we were recently reminded
in the El Paso shooting,
is still very much a live
fantasy of white nationalists.
Obviously, eugenics in
the '50s, '60s, and '70s
was a fierce account of
racialization, not just
of people of color,
especially earlier in the 20th century,
but also of white folks of
trying to produce healthy,
and pure white family, right?
Without visible signs of disability.
I've always been interested in
how we live the context of
empire from inside families,
how we live the context of racialization,
how we live the context
of the economy from within families.
And one of the things that
so fascinated me about
what Celeste Ng did in
"Our Missing Hearts"
which I mentioned at the outset,
is that she manages to tell the story
of a dystopic white nationalist
future from inside families.
And so the question of
how we encounter borders,
and bordering,
I think not just in the
U.S. and the Southwest,
but as also a site where we think family
is quite interesting
to me, and horrifying,
as I sort of pursue these questions.
So we remember the Reagan era
as the era of traditional
values and anti-gay stuff,
and fears about single mothers,
and seeing that play out also
as punishing immigrant families
who could not produce
themselves as nuclear, right?
That only certain people
could pick up a child from
immigration detention,
and they had to be
a pretty near approximation
of the nuclear family,
not a cousin, for example.
And we have a long history, too,
of encountering in the United States,
the encounter between tribal
nations and U.S. racism
has long been in terms of
the problem of understanding
a tribal community as not
composed of nuclear families.
And over and over again seeing
it sexualized and racialized,
and turned into an object of war
through specifically thinking
about patterns of sexuality,
and family making.
And, of course, the history
of enslavement is the history
of slavers telling the story
that Black mothers had no
feelings for their children,
and that's why they could be sold apart.
So that's a really long
answer to your question.
- [Audience] Do you want
me to stand or can I sit?
Hi, so I had a question and
maybe a little bit outside of,
I don't know, maybe related
more than I think, but,
so recently there have been, like,
all these new technologies
through which some of these
children now as adults
have tried to reclaim those connections,
and I'm thinking of in Argentina
of all the children
disappear, DNA, and all that.
Can you just talk about
what you've encounter,
and what you've read about that,
and your thoughts on it?
- Sure.
So it's a transnational effort
by Physicians for Human Rights
to actually develop technology
that would allow them
to transform.
In the '80s we had good technology
for being able to identify through DNA
who was your child, right?
That's still the only thing DNA,
by the way, is really good at.
All the stuff where people tell you
you can send your DNA to some bank,
and they'll tell you
what your ethnicity is.
That's not what DNA is good for.
However, those banks are collecting
tons and tons of information
that is being used by law enforcement
to tell stories about
families and relations.
And so to try to solve
crimes through identifying,
oh, it must be this person's son,
this person's half-brother,
but so what
Physicians for Human Rights sought to do
was to figure out if you
could identify the grandmother
of somebody, particularly
because it was groups
identifying as grandmothers
that were at the forefront
of the activism to recover
Argentina's lost children.
And indeed they began to be able to
trace out those relationships.
It was an amazing effort
that brought together people in the U.S.,
people in Argentina,
and people throughout Latin America,
who developed these technologies together.
So one of the things that
feels particularly grim to me
in the United States right now,
is how difficult it feels to
find sources of opposition to
the growing white nationalism.
And the fascinating thing is everybody,
this is a side note, sorry,
but everybody keeps talking about,
oh, we have to think
about Hungary and Poland.
And sure we can think
about Hungary and Poland,
but it's as if we don't live
in the hemisphere of the Americas.
Like it's as if we don't know
how much these ideologies
were developed for the U.S. ruling class
in relationship to Latin America.
Even this anti-trans
stuff people are like,
oh, my God, it's just like, I'm great.
No, oh, my God, it's just like Columbia.
Oh, my God, it's just like Latin America.
And these people know each other.
These people are often
related to each other.
Anyway, so it's important to me
to stay in touch with
Latin American activists
who have faced all of this for decades
with tremendous resources
and tremendous courage.
I don't mean to be flip about this,
but we don't get killed much
in demonstrations, and they do.
I think they've faced
much harsher conditions
than we have for their activism
with much greater courage
than in general people in the
United States have expressed.
And that's not to minimize, actually,
the sheer level of violence
that people encountered
in the summer of 2020 in the
Black Lives Matter protests,
which I still think we don't have a full,
I mean, we have the reports
that tell us that story,
but we don't have that
as a shared narrative
that people were hurt and killed regularly
in those demonstrations by the police,
but by and large,
those kinds of experiences
are more the exception than the rule
in how protest has been
treated in the United States
compared to how it's been
treated in Latin America.
- [Audience] Thank you.
- [Audience] Thank you
very much for your talk,
even though you are
telling a very horrific,
and outraging story.
I was just wondering
what about the families
that have adopted these children?
Do they know what were the conditions
that allowed them to adopt?
And are they openly,
or consciously complicit with this story,
or what's the story there?
- Yeah, thanks for that question.
I went back and forth
about whether to talk
about it in the talk.
So when I was in El Salvador
talking to the lawyers,
and the researchers at Pro-Búsqueda,
they talked about what it
meant to contact families
in the United States.
Obviously, humans are incredibly diverse,
and there are many different experiences.
For example, I'm not thinking of her name,
the title of her book is "Missing Mila."
One adoptive parent of a Salvadoran kid
actually reached out to the
family in Salvador and Honduras,
and fully acknowledged
what was her kid's kind of
difficult to understand account of that.
And she very much had,
or he very much had parents
alive in El Salvador,
and relatives alive in El Salvador.
We also know the story from
the film "Discovering Dominga"
of a Guatemalan young person
whose sister was a missionary,
so had good Spanish,
and a lot of knowledge of Guatemala,
and as Dominga
kept talking about her
experiences, and what she knew,
her sister was able to find her community,
and her surviving relatives.
So I say that as scaffolding
to say what the lawyers at
Pro-Búsqueda had told me
is that the overwhelming
majority of U.S. families
don't even wanna
acknowledge what happened,
and only a handful of them
are willing to have contact.
I've been starting to
think more and more about
how foster care was built
at such a homophobic,
and transphobic institution,
why it's one of the most,
like, explicitly homophobic,
and transphobic wings of the state.
And I think it's related to
why people may be really bad
at figuring out a relationship
to these imperial relations,
which is to say that
evangelical Christians
have embraced adoption,
embraced transnational
adoption, so have Mormons,
but they've embraced it
within a particular
narrative of exclusivity.
And while that's certainly
not all the people
who are involved in
transnational adoption,
it's a disproportionate number of them.
And while sometimes
the experience of understanding the ways,
and this is what I keep thinking about,
and why I keep writing about it,
the ways that the insides of families
become complicit in U.S. empire.
Sometimes that's quite disturbing,
and provocative to people
in the U.S. or Europe,
but for the most part,
all the energy that goes into disavowing
U.S. empire in general is
replicated by families.
- [Audience] Hi, I'm
a history PhD student,
and I've noticed in the last several years
in that discipline there's
been a move towards
using liberalism as a
framework for critiquing
some of the systems of
society that we least like.
- Can you talk.
- [Audience] Yes.
- Yeah, I'm losing you.
- [Audience] Sorry.
For example, like, there
are some scholars who are,
like, carcerality is a
symptom of liberalism
in the liberal state.
Of course, the challenge
with that argument
is that there's non-liberal states
that are extremely carceral,
like China and Russia, for example.
And so I'm just curious if
you think that liberalism
is a useful framework for addressing,
for criticizing the
issues that you've raised?
Is taking children something
that liberal regimes do,
and that's the right entry point
for thinking about these things,
or is that too limiting?
- As I was giving this talk,
I kind of tripped over
the part where I said
we need a good asylum system
because the other way to
say it is we need to abolish
the distinction between
immigrants and asylum seekers.
And that it seems to me is
certainly much closer to what I hope for,
but it seems further away.
And so that's not what I said,
or that's not what I wrote.
And it seems to me that that encapsulates
the problem with using
liberalism right there, right?
Liberalism is a widely shared framework
that we can use to develop
certain kinds of arguments
that are useful to certain people,
but at the end of the day
it's also the problem, right?
And so I think when you raise
the issue of carcerality
that's precisely the point
that liberalism with its
relationship to capitalism,
and its relationship to a
certain account of the family
gives us this system.
And so everyone's always an
exception in liberalism, right?
And we've seen the asylum
and immigration systems
very much operate within the system.
It used to be that
people who were approved for
asylum were approved in blocks,
right?
Cambodians were,
because what we understood was that people
belonged to a common situation.
I'm now stumbling 'cause
I don't wanna, like,
what conservatives operating
within capital "L" liberalism
understood is that liberalism's genius
is to turn everybody into an individual
over and over and over again, right?
I'm thinking about Thatcher saying, right?
There are individuals,
and there are families.
And one of the things that
fascinates me about that line,
so just to finish out the previous.
So now, like, zillions of
lawyers have to be deployed
to each and every single asylum case,
each and every immigration case.
And they're never gonna be enough of us.
They're never enough expert witnesses,
just we've lost, right?
Once everybody becomes an individual,
and not that one shouldn't
care about those individuals,
of course, and their stories,
but that this is how the
system made it so exceptional,
that asylum seekers
would be granted asylum,
that people would be approved as refugees,
that people would be approved
for an immigration visa,
but the other thing that's fascinating
about the Thatcher line
is how much our households
are important to liberalism.
And I could say a lot about that,
and I'm gonna try not to,
but the ways
that we are embedded in households
only as nuclear families, right?
Only nuclear families count
is another way of exceptionalizing
all sorts of people.
And indeed the majority
of people in the world
are not in nuclear
families it's ridiculous.
So anyway, individuals and their families
is how liberalism operates.
- [Stephen] Laura, I wanted
just to follow-up on that.
Part of your title of your talk
is about tactics of terror.
And it strikes me that you've
put a lot of focus today
in the actual talk
about the terror throughout Latin America,
much of it related to U.S. empire.
In the the book you also
talk about terror tactics
against particular racialized communities
within the United States
that you didn't focus as
much attention on here,
Native, Black, Latino, and others.
And I just wanted to invite you
to talk a little bit about that now.
It may relate to this question
of individuation and family,
or it may say something else about
the treatment of people as groups
at moments of emerging
political influence,
or radical threat.
- Yes, thank you for that question.
So the thing I've been trying to argue,
or the thing I tried to argue in the book
is that what we can see
is the use of the tactic
of taking children is
that it's always a political tactic.
It is actually not about individuals.
And so I talk about the
civil rights movement,
and the moment of the
explosion in the size
of the foster care system
being in the context of
school desegregation.
And so at the very moment
that Black communities
are using as a strategy
to sort of present themselves
in their Sunday best
in demonstrations
as respectable people deserving
of citizenship and respect.
The tactic of white supremacists
was to paint them as disreputable,
particularly to focus on single
mothers and their children.
Cutting off welfare was a
strategy to crush support
for civil rights or
terrorized communities.
And that in turn became a
way of separating children
from their parents
by basically starving single
mothers and their children.
And then the community would say,
well, you can't take care of your child.
And so that child should
be placed in foster care.
And the federal government
actually pioneered that strategy
in conversation with Southern states.
I also talk about the ways
that a certain kind of abortion
politics were pioneered
in relationship to the
so-called war on drugs.
And so the accusation that
pregnant women were using drugs,
or especially in Native communities,
that pregnant women were
drinking excessively.
Both of these were embarrassing lies.
I wanna say as often as I can
because it still is troubling.
Cocaine has no affect on a pregnancy.
This hysteria about crack
babies was entirely ginned up,
but what prosecutors were doing,
ambitious anti-abortion
prosecutors were doing,
was trying to produce an
account of fetal personhood
that we now see running
rampant through the land
as an account of why
women can't have autonomy.
Women and trans folks can't
have autonomy over their bodies,
even if there's a six-week fetus
the size of a lentil inside it.
If you're carrying around
a person inside your body,
you become subject
to the protection of
that person by the state,
and that was always the point.
And sometimes people ask me,
so why was the state trying to
save producing this rhetoric
about saving Black babies
and saving Native babies?
And it seems to me that it
never particularly cared about
saving Black babies, or
saving Native babies,
so much as it cared about
depriving Black and
Native women of rights,
and sending them to prison
and jail for being pregnant
as a sort of trial run
for how to push anti-abortion
politics in the United States.
And I talk also about the fights
for the Indian Child Welfare Act,
and laws to limit, or not laws,
but policies to limit the
placement of Black foster kids
in white adoptive homes.
And the fights against those in the 1990s,
and still the Fifth Circuit
just handed down a decision
that seems to threaten the
Indian Child Welfare Act.
And I wanna say that's so crazy.
Like you can't do that, right?
The claim that what the
Indian Child Welfare Act does
is produce Native people
as a racial group,
and that's improper.
It does no such thing.
It produces Native people as
members of a particular polity,
and as members of tribal nations.
It's very explicit about that,
but what the last few years have taught me
is to stop believing that
crazy s**t doesn't happen
in the courts.
Sorry, I couldn't get
through that sentence
without the curse, but, so
that's some of the rest of it.
I point out what I think
we don't say enough,
which is Indian boarding schools
were started by the war department.
They were started as a strategy
to address Indian wars.
They were meant to terrorize people,
and then they were
subsequently supplemented
with religious schools
by the Catholic church,
the Mormons and other Christian groups,
but it's important to remember that,
like, Carlisle Indian School,
most famous of Indian
schools, what is it now?
It's an Army War College.
It never stopped being
a military facility.
And in fact, the legal
basis under which Trump
could give an executive order
for asylum seekers to lose
their kids at the border
without being legally challenged
was precisely the same basis under which
the Indian boarding schools
were enacted as federal policy.
So these things are very
much tied up with each other,
and we are still living their legacy.
Queer families are
losing their kids again.
They always were,
but it was for a time
Black and Latinx queer families
were mostly losing their kids.
And now it's very white
middle class parents
in Texas of trans kids who are saying,
wait, I'm the sort of person
you want to be a foster parent.
I'm sorry, there are
people I follow on Twitter,
and I'm like, please stop,
please don't do that,
but it's actually fascinating
to find coalitions in Texas
between the anti-carceral activists
who wanna end what they call
the family regulation system,
and the foster care system
with very conservative
evangelicals who wanna
homeschool their kids
without interference from the state,
and together with them
are these middle class
parents of trans kids.
So the state will ultimately come after
an awful lot of people.
And perhaps there's some hope in that,
that we can build meaningful
coalitions like that one,
but also others
to stop the taking of children.
- [Audience] Hey, I was
really curious to know
about child taking in Honduras.
- Child taking in?
- [Audience] Honduras,
and also if you could talk
a little bit about why
in El Salvador there were more
cases of recovering children
than in some of the other countries.
If you could just talk
a little bit more about why that could be?
- Civil society.
The ability to build
the civil society group
that could reach across the whole country.
And everybody in El Salvador
more or less speaks Spanish.
Also, the fact that
I'm trying to think of a
word that does some justice.
Very conservative military members,
and members of the dictatorship
stayed in power in Guatemala.
It was extremely difficult to
build anything in Guatemala
that couldn't immediately be torn apart.
I also think that the depth of
people's fears of each other
in Guatemala is, especially,
as Indigenous communities
were pitted against each other
remains a really salient thing.
The other thing is human rights activists
are still getting killed by the police,
and the military in Guatemala.
If you wanna do this work,
you're facing imprisonment or death.
I started doing research in Guatemala
about the time that
somebody in gender studies
at the University of Central America
got disappeared for doing this research.
And I was like, oh, oh.
Hoping that
having the protections of
sort of a U.S. embassy,
which we knew was complicit,
but nevertheless, having
the thing about being white,
and U.S. American gave me some protection,
but it didn't for everybody,
so it's complicated.
- [Audience] Laura, thank you so much.
You've given me so much to think about.
I wanna think with you,
and just ask you to talk a little bit more
about the status of the child
in these different forms of child taking.
I'm struck that in that narrative about
making sure that when you take the child,
you are canceling the future, right?
And seems to me that
what is also the present right now
is we're also living
through all of these other,
you not only have these cases
of actual taking, right?
And the loss, but that
the law has made it,
and the exercise of law enforcement
has also been a way of
holding us in a process
of a lot of other kinds of child taking,
or child taking and potential.
I was thinking about the TPS debates
that are happening right now,
and how that is a slowly unfurling process
of family separation.
I was on a call this morning
'cause I'm giving testimony
for an asylum case
for an Honduran family, a woman.
And she will likely be deported
because her four kids now have
individually gotten asylum papers.
And so the judge has decided
that because those kids
are safe, ostensibly safe,
they're gonna go into foster
care she can be deported.
And so in some cases of
what you are looking at
the child is the direct target of violence
just they themselves,
like when we put kids
in lockup with adults,
and say they're MS-13 and they're animals.
It doesn't matter that they're 11.
It doesn't matter they're 13.
Sometimes it's to hold them,
to hold the parents hostage,
but in so many of these cases,
the cases of genocide and the
killing of political enemies,
I just wanna ask you just
sort of how you think about
the different statuses of the child
in those different acts of child taking
'cause one of the things
that your study shows us
is just how extraordinarily
flexible this form of terror is,
and how just it weaves
itself through the society,
and then the cartels
reproduce the child taking
in their own operations.
I'm just really inviting you to say more
'cause it's so powerful
what you've been sharing.
Thank you.
- I know one of the things
I've thought a lot about is,
or maybe not enough about,
is that I'm actually much
better at thinking about
the ways that child separation
is about the adults.
And I think in that I am
following so many of the
policymakers and ideologues
who are producing the
rationale for child taking,
but at the same time
it's really clear that
it's not like once they get the child,
then they imagine a humane
future for the child, right?
On the contrary they imagine
that gay kids will go
through conversion therapy,
that trans kids will not transition.
They imagine that Spanish speaking kids
will be placed with Anglo
families who don't speak Spanish.
There were some people commenting
from the Trump administration.
I was really trying to figure out,
like, what were they thinking?
And so to some extent they were like,
I don't know, I guess we just
thought they'd go to DHS,
and they'd disappear.
And, like, there was no
way to imagine children.
And I always sort of like
wanna vomit when I think about
Scalia and conservatives claiming
that children in immigration detention,
there was so much visceral testimony
that I didn't wanna quote, right?
It's like, it's horrible,
and I don't wanna sort
of produce the trauma,
but that they then turned around and said,
"Well, of course it's
fine to detain children
as long as conditions are
humane, and obviously they are."
And like how?
Like how do you even sort of say that?
So
part of what's always fascinated me
is the vanishing of children,
like the imagination that
they will be produced as,
I don't know, little white
Americans, or something.
The story you tell from this morning,
I wish I could say it surprises me at all.
There was a moment, of course,
as you know, we all know,
when having children
was a reason to stay
because it was cruel to
children to leave them,
to separate them from their parents.
- [Audience] Or their civil rights.
- Right.
And it's been now decades and decades of,
you can do anything you want to parents
if you can produce any account at all
in which the children are sort of okay.
It used to make me wanna
bang my head against the wall
when I'd hear conservatives
start talking about
anchor babies at precisely the moment
when there was no such
thing anymore, right?
It's like, how does this, so anyway,
you've reached the level
at which I'm completely
incoherent and speechless.
I don't know how to.
- [Stephen] Laura, on the contrary,
you've been incredibly coherent,
and given us a lot to dwell on.
And I wanna thank you for your book,
which I know many people have read,
and would urge everyone to read.
And thank you for being here,
and I know you'll be seeing
some people tomorrow as well
during your stay on campus,
so we're grateful for that as well.
And thank you to everybody
who made this event possible.
Please join me in thanking Laura Briggs.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)